good morning Hank it's Sunday February
15th today I'm going to talk about the
economic stimulus package but before we
get to that you may be wondering John
why are you wearing a gigantic bronze
medal from the 1994 Alabama State
Academic Decathlon tournament well I'll
tell you Hank it's to remind you that
while I am not technically an economist
in 1994 I was declared the third best
economist among high school students
with grade point averages of under 3.0
in the state of Alabama okay so for the
last several decades the prevailing
belief has been that financial markets
when left alone can correct themselves
so you'll have some growth and then
you'll have a little recession and then
some growth and then some recession and
then some growth but on the whole the
curve will go upward and it's important
to say that recessions aren't inherently
evil like recessions aren't fatal
diseases they're just natural
Corrections that follow periods of what
Alan Greenspan once famously called
irrational exuberance which is my
favorite kind of exuberance Hank I know
that already all the flame fingered
commenters are preparing to write about
how I'm either a communist or a tyrant
and I don't know what I'm talking about
but if that's the case how do you
explain this guy the prevailing belief
among economists has been to let the
economy reset itself at a lower number
and then begin to grow again but then
occasionally the bubble that bursts is
so big that the recession that follows
becomes a vicious cycle basically people
in institutions spend less because
they're scared which causes people and
institutions to produce less which
causes jobs to get cut which causes
people in institutions to spend less
because they're scared and have less
money and so on and so forth until you
have the Great Depression now Hank
obviously we're not in a great
depression I know because I don't have
to walk barefoot to school uphill both
ways 12 miles in the snow and because I
don't just deal tomatoes to survive like
Danny and pawpaw did so when a recession
is that bad what do you do do you let
the unregulated free market reset itself
to a lower number and then you rock it
back to the top some people say yes but
Hank respectfully those people are crazy
there are a bunch of things that you can
do other than nothing the thing we're
going to try is some Keynesian economics
John Maynard Keynes was probably the
most important economist of the 20th
century and he explained that if during
the Great Depression we had had a sort
of massive stimulus bill like say World
War two we could have come out of the
Great Depression
now Keynes has been a little bit out of
favor in the last thirty years but look
we're putting him out of favor got us
Keynes believe that when you got into
one of these spirals the government
needed to go in lower taxes and raise
spending to create economic activity
where the private sector couldn't then
when things rebound you raise taxes back
up and cut government spending now Hank
I don't know if you know a lot of
politicians but in my experience very
few of them are in favor of both raising
taxes and cutting spending which is one
of the big problems with Keynesian
economics politicians take it as a kind
of like blanket excuse to go and spend
money and cut taxes and it is extremely
unfortunate that we had this gigantic
national debt because during all of the
last 30 years when the economy was
basically growing at a great clip we
were still somehow spending more than we
got but all of that aside if we want to
avoid that spiral of misery now is the
time when we have to cut taxes and raise
spending which is precisely with the
economic stimulus bill the president
will sign tomorrow is designed to do
okay so broadly speaking we can divide
the 787 billion dollar stimulus bill
into three sections first 212 billion
dollars in tax breaks
now instead of giving out lump sum
checks like we did in the past the
strategy here is to give people a little
bit of money each week because what
we've learned is that when you give
people a lump sum check they don't spend
it and we need to reset consumer
spending secondly 267 billion dollars
for social services like food stamps and
unemployment benefits and lastly 300
billion dollars in new government
spending which includes everything from
like improving roads and bridges to
making all health records in America
electronic now anti Keynesian economists
are saying it doesn't matter what you do
no matter how much you spend it's not
going to work and Keynesian economists
almost universally agree that this is
not nearly enough spending now and the
stimulus may or may not work I happen to
think that we're in for a crap storm no
matter what but in the professional
opinion of this former 11th grade
economist it's not stupid and it's not
pork barrel politics
it's an honest attempt to restart the
economy Hank thanks for being awesome
congratulations on having written the
greatest song in the history of music
about anglerfish and I'll see you on
Tuesday